Now that we've enumerated our first four
states, let's use them for something.
One of the challenges with sync adapters
is that they don't return status to
us when they complete.
So we have to use another
mechanism to do that.
Since these states occur before
we have a valid location.
There's no proper way to store this
information in our existing database,
which requires all of the location
fields to be filled out.
The method we're going to use is to
have the sync adapters store the current
location status in a shared preference.
This has some nice advantages.
Namely, it persists after
closing the application.
And we can register a listener to be
notified when the preference changes.